the way that human creativity works is
recombination what we remix that's what
we're really good at we don't come up
with a new wholesale creature we put a
horn on a horse and look at that that's
cool that's like how we create just on a
fundamental level we don't imagine a
color that we've never seen our brains
aren't equipped for that train yourself
to look at something you love and break
it down to why you love it on a
fundamental level and then rebuild it
into something that is your own
hey friends welcome back to deep dive if
you're new here my name is ali and in
each episode i speak to entrepreneurs
authors creators and other inspiring
people about how they got to where they
are and the strategies and tools that we
can learn from them that we can apply on
our shared journey of trying to live our
best lives this episode is a special
episode which is appearing during the
off season between season 2 and 3 of the
podcast and this is actually an
interview i did way back in 2020 during
lockdown with my favorite author of all
time brandon sanderson brandon sanderson
writes absolutely incredible freaking
incredible fantasy books including the
mistborn series which is an absolute
banger the stormlight archive series
which is even more of a banger and he
had the immense honor and privilege of
completing robert jordan's incredible
series the wheel of time and wrote the
final three books in that series and
those were absolute bangers as well
brandon's output is just absolutely
insane he writes books almost faster
than we the fans can actually read them
but his career trajectory is quite
interesting because he actually wrote 13
books before he got recognized and
started to actually make it big anyway
in the conversation we discussed a bunch
of things including how he kept his
writing thing going while holding a
full-time day job to pay the bills even
when his work wasn't being recognized we
talked a little bit about the business
of publishing books and about the idea
of originality and we also talk about
how we can make the work that we have to
do more fun so i really hope you enjoy
this interview with brandon sanderson
today i am
absolutely delighted to be joined by my
favorite author of all time brandon
sanderson brandon thank you so much for
coming on welcome to the show
thank you for having me sorry to make
you uh change around how you work over
here it's quite late so we found a time
that is fine for both of us but perfect
for neither i suspect it's actually been
pretty good for me this is a good reason
to get me out of bed in the morning i
always try and schedule calls at like
eight or nine in the morning just to
force me out of bed and this is like
yeah the the perfect time to do the same
thing honestly different times as we
might talk about it's not eight or nine
that i'm scheduling them but i do
schedule them to give myself a deadline
sometimes
yeah so
on that note you're very much
like you've got a very unusual sleep
schedule what is your what does your day
usually look like so my day i will get
up a lot of times around one i've found
that two
sessions of work are better for me than
one long one about a four-hour session
of writing is really good for me
it's this odd thing where i think this
is similar actually to a lot of work but
you got this like hour of spin up time
and near the end you're starting to spin
down and i run out of steam and if i try
to push that too long either one of
those sides will stretch out and what
i'm really looking for is that time in
the middle that's really effective and i
found for me about four hours gives me a
good two hours of really efficient
riding time in the middle and so i try
to schedule my life around having two of
those and i have always been a bit of a
night owl i find it peaceful to work at
night there are fewer distractions i
spent a lot of my early career before i
broke in working a graveyard shift at a
hotel and so i will stop my work at five
shower for the day get ready this is 5
pm and then hang out with my family and
things until around 10 go back to work
at 10 and right from about 10 until two
and then two until four tends to be just
whatever i want to do goof off time so
to speak whatever i feel like doing at
the time and that works really well for
me it gives me enough time just by
myself doing some sort of hobby or
something but it doesn't overload on it
and it makes sure that each of those
writing sessions is pretty effective so
i've been doing this pretty consistently
since i broke in and before that i was
doing one writing session at night
during the graveyard shift and the day
session was uh going to school or things
like that
nice so if we go all the way back when
did you realize that you wanted to be a
writer
i got to it a little late
later than a lot of people you talk to
novelists and they'll say oh i started
my first concept was in the womb and by
the time i was two i was working on my
first piece of uh poetry or whatever i
discovered books when i was a teenager i
was 14 i had a good teacher who got me
into reading and i found something in
books that i had been missing in my life
without some sort of connection
specifically to fantasy and science
fiction there was something about the
wonder the world building mixed with
interesting concepts and philosophy and
just the whole package really grabbed me
and even as young as like 14 i'm like
man i wonder if i could do this i don't
think i really started giving it a shot
and considering it like professionally
until i was 17 or so and i finished my
first
novel the first thing i got done i was
22 and so i count 22 that that age
that's when it's like all right i have
decided i've moved my major from
chemistry to english and i am just going
to
throw my hat in the ring and do my best
to become a writer
nice and am i right in saying that that
you wrote 13 books before one of them
one of them was sold
yes i did i
then for the next eight years or so
eight or nine years i wrote two books a
year ish on average for yeah i guess so
more around a little less than two books
a year but you know what i mean i
eventually sold my first let's see i
sold my first in 2003 and so
i would have been 28. so it's a little
less than eight years more like six
years so it was about two books a year i
wrote 13 novels i sold my sixth one
right when i was just polishing up the
13th that was 2003 that came out in
2005.
so right around when i turned 30 is when
my career officially began okay and that
was elantra's was it that was the
launchers yep so during this like sort
of six to eight year period where you're
writing on average two books a year and
you haven't you haven't sold any books
yet so you're not making any any money
off of the writing itself
how did you keep yourself going that
this is what i want to do and i can see
the light at the end of the tunnel like
what was the thought process back then
yeah i often talk about one of the big
moments in my career happened before i
had a career and this is when i was
writing those back novels the 10 through
13 where i was starting to think
everyone told me that this was a really
hard job to do and that my chances were
really some which by the way they are
less slim than people will tell you my
experience has been that people who
really dedicate themselves to the craft
and things it's more like one out of 20
or 30 who end up going on to have a
career as opposed to one out of a
million like everyone told me but if you
went to med school and they said yeah
you're gonna go through all of med
school and you're gonna have a one out
of twenty chance of becoming a doctor i
think maybe you would have rethought uh
some of what you were doing it's still a
difficult job to get to work because
it's in entertainment but it's not as
crazy difficult as people pretend it is
but that's different conversation during
those years i'm like okay
maybe i'm one of the 19 who really
enjoys this but is just not writing
things that match the market really well
and maybe i will not ever have a career
and i came to the decision that i had to
be okay with that that writing was
something i did because first and
foremost i really loved doing it and i
thought think it makes me a better
made me a better person i use the the
metaphor of basketball actually to mix
metaphors
a little bit between writing and sports
but i have friends who go play
basketball we're in our 40s none of us
are going to the nba but i have friends
that regularly they'll just go play
basketball
why they enjoy it it's good for them
it's really a great thing and my
publicist loves to go golfing he is not
going to end up on the pga tour that's
just you know not a thing that's going
to happen in his life but nobody asks
him when you're going to go pro but if
you start writing a book people will ask
you when you're going to publish it when
will you monetize this thing and don't
get me wrong i think monetizing the
thing that you're working on is totally
a great idea um and maybe we'll talk
more about that and things like that but
understand that
if you want a stable career and you want
to earn well writing is not the thing to
do that's not the reason to do it i i've
made this decision i said you know what
if i hit
let's be aspirational if i hit age 99
and i have written a hundred novels that
have not been published that's okay you
know what i'm a bigger success than if i
give up now because i'm giving up on
something that i truly love and maybe i
have to scale back get her get a real
job quote unquote i was in grad school
at the time
get a real job have a real career find
something that i enjoy and
writing becomes my hobby and
i was okay with that i didn't want that
to happen but i was okay with it i was
willing to take that and go with it and
that was a big important sort of moment
for me realizing that i legitimately
just enjoyed doing this it was extremely
fulfilling and i was going to keep going
and for me i
got lucky right i'm the one out of 20.
what i happen to write
matches the market really well i have
some natural talent i've been able to
expand upon and i was in the right place
at the right time for a number of
publishing opportunities and my career
has really worked out i have friends
though who they're also the one out of
twenty they aren't best sellers but
they've made a career out of writing and
uh they enjoy it just as much and so
it's
you don't have to become astronomically
successful to have a career but you do
have to be willing to take that risk
that
maybe you won't have a career and this
will be your hobby and just a dedicated
hobby that is a big part of your
self-identity most likely for most
writers yeah so it's as part of this
equation of you know help helping us
figure out what to do with our lives
in a way it it seems like there's
broadly like two strands of it there's
one strand which is a
find find something that you enjoy and
do it and then there's another strand
which is like find enjoyment in the
things that you're doing
and it sounds like for you writing
writing was that thing of you found
something you were passionate about and
you found that you that you enjoyed it
as well
do you have any thoughts or advice for
people who are in that position where
they're like i'm not really sure what
i'm passionate about like
what how do you think about that
yeah it is hard in some ways because
i've noticed this in some of my friends
some of my roommates in college and
things like this where i had this
all-consuming passion and i was going
for broke if i didn't end up selling my
fallback jobs were not the same sort of
caliber right it's i end up becoming an
insurance salesman or something i i
couldn't really have even become a
professor because becoming at least in
the states an english professor requires
certain hoops to jump through for phds
and things that i just was not doing in
grad school i wasn't working on the
papers in the journals and all this
stuff and so i was all in
on this and i had a roommate who one at
one point told me brandon not all of us
are like that i
i do not have an all-consuming passion i
want to find a job i want to enjoy it
and i want to come home and play video
games and that is still how he is he's
in my writing group and i basically i
was myopic early before in my
pre-published years because i had this
everyone must have this all-consuming
passion sort of thing which i just don't
think is true i think there are a lot of
very fulfilling jobs out there and in
fact one of the things that i often say
to people is if you are a writer do you
really like writing programming and
writing
feel very similar in fact i had to stop
taking i took a programming class in
college and after it i'm like i can
never take another one of these because
that semester was the hardest i ever had
writing because i would do my homework
and then i'd feel like i'd already
written for the day when i'd been coding
and it would leave me mentally exhausted
and most of my other classes use a
different part of my brain
coding is basically writing it's the
same sort of thing when you're writing a
novel you are problem solving how to
achieve these things you want to these
results you want to get out and so the
output is reader investment and emotion
rather than the outputs that you might
have for the object you're you're coding
or something like this but i think that
you can um
humans are they're things that drive us
one is creativity being able to make
something but another is serving people
i actually think the best i had a lot of
fun working a graveyard shift to the
hotel being able to be the person that
at night when somebody needed something
at the hotel i just got it for them i
made them happy i didn't have to sell a
single thing because no one was coming
in and buying rooms i was just there to
make their experience better and i found
that wildly fulfilling shockingly
fulfilling for me now of course i was
writing at the same time i'm at the
front desk typing away interrupted to go
get somebody something they need and so
it was a k was a good match of the two
things but i think that acknowledging
what it is that that human beings
generally find fulfilling finding out
what it is you find fulfilling is it
finding a need and fulfilling it is it
being able to be creative is it problem
solving you can find these general
groupings of things that you happen to
find satisfying fulfilling and you can
then find a whole bunch of different
careers and things that that target in
that that grouping of yours and just
like writing computer programming you're
very similar there's a lot of things
like that out there and i often say try
a bunch of different things i wish that
our college and profession building how
can i even phrase this the way that we
prepare people for the workplace i wish
it involved a lot more variety i wish
there were more opportunities for us to
try different things out to try
different jobs out try different majors
out and really find what people find
fulfilling in them because if i hadn't
had
this teacher get me into reading who
knows what would have happened with me
and i everyone thought i was a reluctant
reader that i didn't like reading when
the truth was i just had not found the
right books yet it was the world
building and fantasy novels that made
the difference and then i became a huge
reader but before that my teachers were
saying to my parents like he just
doesn't like reading he's just not a
reader find a career for him that
doesn't involve a lot of that
um
yeah it's so interesting how just the
right person at the right place at the
right time can completely change the
trajectory of your life
and i've definitely had that happen a
few times with me it's interesting this
thing you say about about the graveyard
shifts at the hotel you were working at
because because that was basically
exactly what i was doing on my night
shift to the hospital where i used to
really enjoy night shifts because
generally it's quite quiet you don't
usually have new patients coming in the
door and it's normally just a case of a
nurse rings you up or bleeps you and
wants something prescribed for their
patients and because the hospital i was
working at had like electronic
prescribing i could sit at the front
desk in their plushy kind of chairs with
two computer screens in front of me one
that had the electronic health record
and the other one that had like a
document open where i was planning my
youtube videos and i'd get a call i'd
prescribe the thing or occasionally go
see a patient i got so much like
non-doctor stuff done during those
shifts so i used to really enjoy night
shifts and all my friends used to be
like oh my god i i
found one on purpose i actually had
known someone who worked as a security
guard and was like wow i get to read all
kinds of books at night it's great and i
thought i'm a night owl i should find a
job like that and i went and tried
actively to find one and i was very
upfront with the people to tell i said
i'm doing this because i want to spend i
want to have some free time at work to
work on my riding they're like great the
last guy we had fell asleep on the couch
this doesn't work for everyone by the
way those are listening like ooh i'm
going to go become a graveyard shift be
aware that larger hotels
generally have things they expect the
night auditors to do they don't let just
sit at the desk and not do stuff
you're like folding towels or things
like that i found a job luckily they
didn't do that but also a lot of people
just aren't productive during those
hours i've had a friend who wanted to
become a writer who went and got a job
at the same place that i had worked and
it was a disaster it was several months
of
him trying to adjust his schedule to do
the brandon shift and it not working at
all and it just happened that was how
i'd worked since high school i had
actually generally in high school i was
staying up late going to sleep for four
hours going to school coming home and
sleeping for another four hours and then
getting up which was an odd schedule for
a high school student and i don't
recommend it but i was basically already
doing this yeah that makes a lot of
sense this is something i'm starting to
look into as well this idea of everyone
has their own how everyone has a
specific chrono type in terms of are you
a night owl are you an early bird and
and so on and so i've got some friends
who are really into sports medicine
where they analyze athletes to figure
out their optimum performance so i'm
going to try and get one of them on my
youtube channel so i can have this
analysis done for free i find that all
really interesting because i don't think
we really know yet like it seems all
very speculative when i read about it
all i know is that i generally keep
falling into the same sleep schedule i
tried to get off of it when i was first
married and my wife was not thrilled by
the idea of me going to bed at four or
five and her getting up at six for
school for a few months i i tried my
best and it was just miserable i did not
adjust and eventually she's like okay
just go back to your schedule this is
miserable for both of us
nice
so one book i have on on my desk at all
times is austin cleon's still like an
artist i don't if you come across it how
do you think about like other fantasy
writers and like getting inspiration
from them and and also vice versa like
you're such a huge name in fantasy that
lots of people are probably now
massively inspired by you so how do you
think about that in terms of like ideas
and collaboration and plagiarism and all
that kind of stuff so i think in general
authors worry a little too much
about coming off as derivative and now
your early books are gonna feel really
derivative that does happen like my
first unpublished book feels very
derivative this is why we don't publish
our first books and it's really okay i
am never going to
fear like
i'm not one that's afraid of being
plagiarized right like
you authors develop their own voices and
their own ways of doing anything and if
you give two authors the same concept
they will come up with wildly different
books and i think that
really the way that human creativity
works is recombination we remix that's
what we're really good at we don't uh we
don't come up with a new wholesale
creature we put a horn on a horse and
look at that that's cool that's like how
we create just on a fundamental letter
level we don't imagine a color that
we've never seen our brains aren't
equipped for that what we can do is we
can imagine something that is usually
one color with a different color and
kind of play with that and theme and
things like that i do think that you do
have to be worried about um
a little bit about being derivative but
not terribly much in my class with my
students i talk about the difference
between what i call a chef and a cook i
am a cook when it comes to actual food
this means you give me a recipe and i
can follow it and generally get the
thing that i'm supposed to be making
but if i do something wrong or if i
haven't accounted for something i have
no idea how to fix it if the recipe just
doesn't turn out i'll have just no clue
a chef would be able to say oh you're at
a different elevation that causes this
effect that's why this bake turned out
differently you need to do this thing
and this and tweak this or your butter
was melted and it was too melty and so
you got this result as a writer i
encourage
my students to try to think of
themselves like chefs rather than cooks
which is
train yourself to look at something you
love and break it down to why you love
it on a fundamental level and then
rebuild it into something that is your
own and i think that's just a very
useful skill for creators to have and
this is where you start to make these
connections where you're like wow a
buddy cop movie in a c and a
romantic comedy often have the same plot
structure why is that why what are we
loving about these things how can i use
an element from that what is a heist i
love heist movies can i create and you
end up with something really cool like
inception which is a heist but unlike
any you've ever seen it follows the
heist beats really well but it still
feels wholly original because
christopher nolan and his brother have
broken this thing down and looked at
what they really love about what makes a
heist work and then they have created
their own version of it that does
something new and original if you can
learn to do that if you can learn to to
boil it down to what you love and take
that core element and build something
new around it you will be a successful
storyteller i am convinced
yeah it's exactly the same with for
example youtube as well like i teach a
lot of people how to how to do well on
youtube and it really is this case of
look at other people that you like the
videos of figure it out figure out what
it is about those things that you like
and then think about incorporating those
into your thing into your own videos and
not worrying too much about like
originality at the start because
in your quest to be like someone else
that you like you'll end up finding your
own voice and kind of doing it your own
way yeah i actually kind of noticed this
in youtube i i like i like the kind of
infotainment youtube quite a bit and the
video essays and things like that and
years ago bill wurtz dropped a kind of
history of japan video and then it was
wildly successful it's this awesome
piece of media it's really innovative
and interesting and then you just
basically didn't do anything more like
that now five seven years later wherever
we are now there's like entire channels
that are based around these kind of
comedic retelling of factual events that
kind of owe their dna to bill where's
doing this thing and being really
successful and then just he wants to go
off and make music and so he does that
instead and they all feel different they
all feel original and they're all
feeling this hole that
nobody knew that they wanted but they
did and it's been fun to
really watch that and a few of them even
acknowledge hey i watched this bill
wurtz video no one was making these
things so now i am i'm doing it and a
lot of these things have hundreds of
thousands of subscribers that are making
really interesting original content all
because one person made this thing that
had such an effect on the market so to
speak the industry so changing gears a
little bit uh we talked a bit earlier
about the
idea of finding something that you're
passionate about and going for that and
and you were lucky in a way because you
found this thing writing that you were
super passionate about
i'd love to get your thoughts on the
other side of the equation which is
finding joy in the things that we're
doing
and there was a quote from one of your
one of i think from one of your classes
where you said
success is
success involves making yourself do the
things you want to have done i wonder if
you can just grip on that for a little
bit
yeah i totally can this is kind of a a
hobby horse of mine so to speak a
personal philosophy if you will i truly
enjoy writing but it is also still work
and there are parts of it i like less
than other parts and the part i like the
most is writing the end and then letting
people read the book the experience of
knowing people now get to read this
thing that i've created that's just
that's the top that's what i want to do
but to get there
i need to spend between 6 and 18 months
working on a story in a dedicated very
slow and steady way in order to have
this thing that i can show to people and
some of those days i'm really gonna love
working on it and on most of those days
i'm going to be like once i get into it
i'm really enjoying it but i have to
force myself to start working as much as
i enjoy writing playing another game of
civilization would probably be more pure
dopamine hit than working on my books i
looked at my career and how i made
myself do stuff early in my career
before i got published it was uh a stick
instead of a carrot i saw i joked that i
saw a phantom cubicle chasing me and if
i didn't write my books i was going to
have to let it capture me um and spit me
out as a salesman or something like that
but very quickly that stopped being a
good motivation for me and what started
working was me realizing i love watching
numbers count up on a spreadsheet and
the simple fact of keeping track of my
daily word count would make me more
likely to write the next day because i
liked seeing myself inch closer and
closer to that goal of finishing
something and finishing it was so
satisfying that i was able to kind of
further that and be like each day i have
finished something and the the
percentage counts up and i'm that much
closer to being finished and that works
really well for me we talk about
gamification that's a bit of a
experience bar gamification at times in
my life a carrot has worked also it
stopped working as soon as i got even a
little bit of success early before i
when i was newer and younger it could be
like my nerd hobby is managed at the
gathering and i could be like i can open
a pack of magic cards if i finish my
work for whatever this week or whatever
i can open up one of these packs and
look at my new cards once i achieved
success to the point that a pack of
magic cards was no longer like i could
buy a hundred packs each day and it
wouldn't noticeably affect my bank
account the the carrots stopped being
effective for me and fortunately i had
this whole structure in place by then
once it became a career because you know
earlier in my career one of the things
that uh was is interesting is that my
writing time was in many ways more
precious
because i only had those few hours at
night and during the day i wouldn't be
able to write too much school going on
homework all these things and so at when
midnight rolled around at uh work at the
hotel and i had that time to write that
was precious time to me and before i got
that job i even it was even more
precious because i couldn't write at
work and so i'd have like an hour a week
or things like this where it's just like
this time is my golden time and i
cherished it it became harder to write
when i got more time in some ways
because suddenly writing time was not a
precious commodity in the same way i
talk about learning to hack your brain
find out what motivates you
on a day-to-day basis and figure out how
your brain works and the things you can
do kind of to trick yourself into doing
what you want to have done because if
you do this the right way the days
become very satisfying you'll notice
like for me if i get my word count and
then i get to go play a video game for a
couple of hours and i've also spent
three hours with my kids playing their
games or doing things with them and a
couple hours of my wife doing what she
wants to do when i retire for the day i
just feel incredibly fulfilled right
like i've got good family time i've
gotten so much of my work done because
i've made myself do it i even had a few
hours just to goof off and recently it
was playing bowser's fury on the switch
and i'm like hey my kid bought this
let's play an old school mario game and
it's just it's a really light good
balance for me other people work in
different ways there are people who that
binging is better there are binge
writers who are like i need three months
to write a book and to do nothing else
during that time and then i spent the
other nine months of the year just
gearing up for the next book doing some
revisions and and things like this
that's not me slow and steady make every
day satisfying don't put off to be like
i'll be happy in the future be happy now
by making a good work life balance and
spending time with family and what it is
just pretty wonderful i highly recommend
getting to a place in your life where
you are feeling like that when you go to
bed each day yeah
this is it's kind of funny because often
if i'm interviewed on a podcast or
something and i'm talking about this
topic
the line that i just land on is journey
before destination
and i think that's just such a good like
mantra for life and it seems like you've
really you're really living that
yourself
yeah a lot of artists and writers i know
they do not have a good balance in life
and people often come to me and they're
like why are you so prolific and i'm
really not if you look back at the
highly profit prolific writers during
the pulp days when it was if they didn't
turn in their pages they get paid by the
word so they turned in their pages and
the pay was not good these people were
doing way more but i feel like we at
artists just don't tend to have good
structures in life build around helping
them get to uh product productive
effective long-term productivity that
other businesses do they understand this
and there's like this entire culture at
places like google centered around let's
make sure that you remain productive a
for a long time and writers have to be
self-motivated no one's there um telling
you do your work you don't have a lot of
external motivation my my roommate in
college tom he picked his major by
looking at which majors earned the most
with only a four-year degree he didn't
want to go to professional uh school or
to get an advanced degree what would be
the highest earning and at that time at
the school he we went to it was chemical
engineering so we just picked that and
they had a very rigid schedule for four
years if you wanted to be a chemical
engineer like every class was picked for
you and you were taking these classes i
assume you have maybe had some of this
in your life where it's like you try
really hard to get a 65 percent on the
test because that's you that's going to
be a b you're going to be fine where i'm
over here in english where we're dancing
through fields and flowers and talking
about our feelings and reading jane
austen and nobody is saying here's what
you do to actually turn into an author
they're all just talking about our
feelings and if you get 65 on a test
then you're just like mortified um like
that's just not okay and these two
different worlds couldn't be more
opposite and i think a lot of artists
are in this kind of thing particularly
writers because even in the visual arts
you end up with people who can counsel
more but so few people understand how to
make a living as a writer you end up
with all these people just bumbling
through it on their own and it's no
wonder that they don't have you know
good work life balance and things like
this because
how do you build habits like this when
no one talks about it when everyone says
what you do is you feel your inner muse
and then when your inner muse speaks to
you you let it out and this color flows
onto the page that's how you write a
book and you sit in these classes you're
like
okay but then what anyway i i feel like
writing has a lot of dysfunctional
people who are
function they're good they're trying
very hard but their lives through no
follow their own have become very
dysfunctional
yeah there's a quote that i think again
from one of your one of your youtube
videos uh which was which was probably
from one of you one of your classes
which is that you you think of yourself
as an artist with the work ethic of an
accountant
is that fair to say yeah
yeah that my mom was an accountant
before she retired and she she taught me
good work ethic when i was young and
she doesn't understand fantasy novels
she she reads my books because they're
mine but she she trained me in a really
solid work ethic like i had a job when i
was 14 and it was paper out right like a
little self-employed thing and there
were she was setting up these kind of
ways that i go about it how i accounted
i had to account it myself kid of an
accountant and i applied a lot of that
to becoming a writer because i am more
ahead in the clouds type person um than
i am naturally an accountant but i had
that really good training as a kid and
it has served me very well yeah i think
for a lot of people it's a bit and like
for for all of us it's really this
balance of like how can we make like how
can we make the stuff that we're doing
more fun so that where we actually do it
and it in a way it does need us to
talk ourselves into doing it there's a
lot of times where i can't be bothered
to film a youtube video but i do it
anyway and then once i get started i'm
like oh i know this is fun because i
like the sound of my own voice and then
when i'm done with it i'm like oh this
is great and i've just done another
video and i'm so glad i forced myself to
do it at that and that early stage and i
think if you fall off at that early
stage then things don't necessarily
work
yeah yeah totally uh this is so
important in doing any sort of
self-motivated artistic uh or creative
pursuit like youtube though we could
talk for hours i don't want to go down
this path but i do think there are some
dysfunctional things about the way that
we treat work in society and the way
that we like i worry a lot about what we
do to doctors to be relevant there's
this this sense that i don't know how it
is where you live but over here it's
like your first 10 years are going to be
miserable but then life will be good
after that you're going to work these in
incredible shifts since we have to make
the doctors feel pain to make sure that
they deserve than having a higher than
standard living wage later on i just
think that's a terrible idea i think
it's an awful thing to be training
people i think it's awful uh to be
training people if they want to become
attorneys that they're going to have to
go through hell in order to end up being
an attorney and that's the way we
gatekeep who gets to become our
attorneys is the people that are willing
to suffer through hell i think it's just
terrible and i also think that in
general business practices making one of
the things that makes us want to work is
ownership and i don't know that people
are proportionately rewarded for their
work in a lot of businesses and it's
it's important to me for instance that
my kind of full-time employees and
partners they have you know a percentage
of what i make as a bonus every year and
even though it's smaller it's real and
they are part of this when my art
director is working on a book you know
he's pouring his creative energy into
making this book it is his passion as
much as it is mine even though i i've
done the bulk of the words like he is
lending his true genuine artistic talent
to doing the maps and the symbols and
the things this is isaac stewart he
deserves a cut of that not just a salary
in my opinion and i i think that we
disproportionately reward in our society
based on where someone falls in a
certain ladder and things like that but
that's a different conversation but it's
so hard to feel investment for something
you're working on when they say you're
part of our family or things like this
which is very common in corporate speak
over here but you don't get a cut of the
profit you're just part of our family
aren't isn't it great we're a family and
people need to be allowed ownership over
the things that they create because
that is how one of the reasons we feel
fulfilled is this thing that we have
created that we're part of is making
people's lives better in some way yeah
absolutely just on that note one thing
i'm one thing i'm curious about because
i've been thinking about this for my
team who's helping me with the kind of
the youtube and the business and stuff
do you do the sort of
percentage of profits overall from the
business or is it like on a per project
basis or like how do you work this out
for you and your team so for my team it
is i basically have two baskets the
first basket is what i call my officers
these are the people who've been with me
for a long time they work for me full
time and they're involved basically in
everything i'm doing to some extent or
another and these people get a
percentage off of the nets that the
company makes basically
it's what the company's going to pay
taxes on or what i'm going to pay taxes
on uh since it actually just flows
through to me the way the car company
works so what i pay taxes on a
percentage of that is a yearly bonus
that is not counting their salary i
still pay them a salary going at market
rate and then there's this on top of it
the other basket is the people who work
on my store and these are the people
that are doing the online orders are
kickstarter and things like that and
their bonuses are based on store revenue
directly rather than the whole books
revenue i mean so we have those two
different baskets for people and when i
hired my very first employee this is
peter alstrom he's my editorial director
and he had been for years working with
me and
just for free as a friend reading my
books and offering feedback and his
feedback was just fantastic he
eventually became a professional editor
working at tokyopop bringing manga over
to the us and and things like that and i
hired him and i said i want to give you
a percent right now the business is not
huge i hope that this sunday will be
worth lots but it's important to me
that that your creative
energy because i feel that accountants
are creative i feel that editors are
creative like it's a different kind of
creativity my mom always says i'm not
creative at all i'm like the way that
you have set up your life is super
creative and right from the get-go i
said i think this is important i feel
like i wouldn't want to be involved in
something unless i was seeing part
ownership to me and that percentage is
is actually theirs to pass on to their
descendants like it's not just a wage
working for me it is like they have
built with me
this business and a piece of it is
theirs and that's every time i've gone
there usually it takes a few years of
someone working here before i invite
them on as an officer and things like
that but it is the way that i approach
my business and you know what i think it
is the moral way and i'm not saying that
there aren't other businesses that do
this they do this with stock in a lot of
companies it's totally it totally
happens i just feel like it doesn't
happen on the extent that perhaps it
should it's like you have to fight for
these things as a worker rather than it
being offered directly to you i don't
like this sort of community where people
don't talk about their salaries and
corporations try to get what whatever
they can out of the people working for
them this is just not a good way to have
productive fulfilled people working in
the company and there's my diatribe
diatribe out i basically barely know
what i'm talking about i have like you
know 20 employees what do i know about
large-scale corporate uh sort of things
but as a small business owner these are
my philosophies
i know we're on the hour but if you've
got a few more minutes i've got a few
more questions from the chat and some
stuff i'd love to ask you uh okay so
with the book that i'm writing i'm
annoyingly looking at the goal of
hitting the new york times bestseller
list i've i feel dirty admitting it
because
a lot of authors
that i've seen interviews would say
there's a lot of baggage associated with
having the goal of i want a new york
times bestseller
what was that like for you hitting the
list and is it do you think it's a
reasonable goal for someone like me to
to have in my sights or should i
because i feel like it conflicts with
the journey before destination which has
become one of my one of my mantras for
life i don't think it is a bad goal for
you to have and i'll tell you why
journey before destination doesn't mean
don't think about the destination goals
of where we want to get yes you need to
enjoy the process of writing the book or
you'll never get to that destination but
the goal is to have a finished book
there is a goal there and for a lot of
new authors i would say don't have
hitting the list as a goal on your first
book because you can't control that but
you can you have an audience you're
already established you're doing a
nonfiction book tied into what you
actually you do on your youtube channel
uh this is a very reasonable goal in
fact i think it is well within um
the means and it is something that can
help you to make the decisions during
the journey toward what you want to
accomplish and understanding the list
and how it happens and things like that
is handy in this regard yeah hitting the
list the first time was very is a very
gratifying moment because once you hit
the list once you are a best seller for
life you have been a best seller and
that's really cool the kind of companion
of that though is that hitting the list
is a different thing than a lot of
people think it is books don't generally
sell as many copies particularly during
the what we call the mid list or the
high uh the low best sellers or the high
mid list that people think so in fiction
hardcover
to get the very bottom of the list in
the years where i was uh breaking in you
needed about 2 000 copies in a week to
get onto the list that was your
threshold because a very successful
mid-lister would sell 20 000 copies
total in its life in hardcover that was
considered really successful the
launcher sold 10 000. for a break brand
new author that was really good in fact
uh that's one of the at least during
that era was one of the thresholds if
you were selling 10 000 copies in
hardcover you would never be dropped by
your publisher you would always have a
career that was all considered a
successful mid-list book you would
probably even start hitting the
best-seller list as your name
grows more people front load and the
list is all about front loading right
you can have books that do very well
they're selling 1900 copies a week
and therefore never hitting the list but
they do it for 50 weeks and i end up
outselling the books that hit the list
list is a measure of momentum not a
measure of total sales having momentum
this is why it's totally valid that you
would want to hit the list i don't know
what it is in non-fiction by the way and
i don't know it has changed over the
years the list is always undergoing
these revolutions and things when i
broke in there were 25 places on the new
york times bestseller list in fiction i
don't know if there's still 25 places
and i hit like number 25 with 2200
copies or something like that it can
vary to get the top spots in fiction
during a competitive month on the new
york times you need probably 120 000
copies in a week but this is weirdly
changed by ebook plus hardcover it used
to just be hardcovers now they have a
separate list that's ebooks and
hardcovers but it doesn't count
audiobooks but this other list does
count audiobooks and things like that
the new york times list was really
opaque for many years and no one kind of
knew how they were picking their books
and then the nielsen ratings for books
started happening and at least in
fiction the new york times list pretty
much follows the actual sales numbers as
recorded in the nielsen ratings these
days it may be different in non-fiction
more shenanigans happen in non-fiction
there are more people who have platforms
and know how to use them and also have
means behind them to perhaps game the
list a little bit it's all
this is what your readers are your your
viewers should keep in mind and never
should keep in mind it is a marketing
term bestseller is a marketing term and
it is used like a marking term it is not
a stamp of quality but it is
when it's working right a stamp of
momentum that a book
it's a reasonable goal to have but enjoy
the journey along the way we've got a
lot of questions from the chat and this
is something i'm very curious about as
well changing gears what is
what's your like
technology stack when it comes to
writing what are the tools that you use
for this
so i am fairly low-tech microsoft word
is my writing platform of choice the
only tool that i use that a lot of uh
people don't use is i do have a wiki
it's a personal wiki it's an open source
software program called wicked pad and
it's for me and my team to keep track of
continuity in the cosmere books and
that's only inward facing that's not
outward facing fans can't go to that but
it is there uh it's not even on the
internet it's hosted locally just for us
and that is is really handy i find the
wiki way of thinking just it's easy to
look things up it's easier than
encyclopedia entries and whatnot so
i do recommend that but i write the
books in microsoft word pretty old
school start on start with word one and
write to the end of the chapter sort of
stuff and then i usually have a notes
file that's a separate file and then a
an outline file that's a separate file
and then a what i call a floating
outline it's the short term outline of
the stuff i'm doing immediately next as
a separate file okay again shifting
gears
period of my own curiosity to what
extent do you look at like 17th shard
people
fan theories about what's going to
happen in future books and to what
extent does that guide your decision
making about what's going to happen in
future books i don't spend a lot of time
with that i understand it i was part of
that for the wheel of time fandom i went
to those sites and things like that
before i was in long before i was
involved and i totally get it i am happy
those people are there i like that
they're making lots of interesting
theories but i have learned from let's
just say i've seen what other authors
have done and it's generally i recommend
against changing what you're going to do
because people are theorizing in the
right or wrong direction either way and
i have this thing that if you do your
job well as a writer that means that
upcoming twists and turns are
foreshadowed and nothing's completely
out of nowhere except for you there's
the occasional sort of thing that's
supposed to be a surprise to the
characters an unexpected illness or
death can happen in any book you don't
have to necessarily foreshadow that but
plot twists and turns in general i am
going to lay foundation for big world
building surprises that might be
surprises to the casual reader just will
not be surprises to the to the
entrenched reader this kind of plays
into my philosophy on world building i i
have this thing i i call fractal world
building i like world building where big
picture someone who is a casual fan who
reads the book is able to see the big
picture and understand it and someone
who wants to dig in deep the closer they
zoom you know fractal gets more detailed
the more you look at it that's kind of
one of the features the more
detail you look at the world building
the more interesting things you find to
explore and to talk about so it's kind
of this two-prong thing don't make it so
obtuse that the casual fan is lost but
don't make it so
uh simple and surface level that there's
nowhere to dig i mean try to do both at
once if you can very easy to understand
on the large scale very complex under
the hood so to speak and because of this
i'm just not going to surprise those
people because
i want them to figure it out i want it
to be there for them and i've learned
that it's madness to try to to trick
them just for the fact of haha you
didn't expect that just not how i work i
don't think ultimately that's going to
create a satisfying series it's like
trading off the long term satisfaction
of your series for the short term being
able to punch someone in the face um and
not have them see it coming so i want to
take sound bites from this chat and make
it into like a something
suitably clickbaity like interviewing
the world's most productive writer or
something like that i wonder if you can
just toss out a few other random
productivity tips you have because it
would be useful to chop into the video
how are you so productive as a writer
let's see what i got i feel that writing
wise
knowing my destination is really
important i outline backward and i write
forward and i think this is very strong
for me because i know where i'm going i
always have momentum because i'm pushing
towards something that i think is going
to be really exciting you have to make
sure that each chapter can be somebody's
favorite this is one of the mantras of
my editorial director he says don't
write a chapter that can't conceivably
be someone's favorite it doesn't have to
be everyone's favorite but there should
be something in every chapter that some
readers can be like i love this don't
make any chapter the boring filler make
sure that the boring filler is exciting
and interesting in its own right maybe
just a different type of exciting and i
think that works in life as well make
every thing you're doing
exciting and uh interesting to you in
some way even if it's not your favorite
part of the process i do not like
revision very much revision is my least
favorite part of the writing process but
one of the things i've been able to do
to make myself excited about it is i
create an outline for my revision i
really like the outlining process of
books it's one of my favorite parts it's
this exploration this world building so
the fun of creating an outline for this
is what my revision is going to
accomplish and this is what it's going
to look like when i'm done gives me that
same feel for the parts of it that i
really love that makes the revisions
more interesting to me because it's
goal-based rather than just oh man i
have this broken book i've got to fix
instead i've got oh i get to implement
this new thing that's going to make the
book so much more interesting let's go
and do this that's going to be more
exciting so i really enjoy doing that
one productivity tip i have for creative
professionals it's worked very well for
me is i try to make sure that all of my
non-writing things
are segregated into a single day i have
one day's work that i can spend on
interviews that i can spend on meetings
that i can spend on working on my class
for instance all the things that are s
beside
my career doing youtube videos all of
this those all lie
fall on thursdays for me and i have a
limited number of hours and a thursday
and my whole team knows that those hours
that's all they're going to get we can't
let that overflow because it's very easy
to let the
non-productive things that are still
important
overshadow
actually creating new content as a
creative professional you could spend
forever on publicity you could spend
forever creating all these things doing
all these interviews and then stop
writing books and so for me my life got
better when i said i'm just gonna like
ripping off a band-aid i'm gonna do all
these things on the same day and i'm
gonna limit it to these hours and now
when something comes up that we need to
do that we're like oh we totally need to
do this well the thursday's full so
we'll schedule that for next thursday
and we just have to tell the people
brandon's next hole in his schedule is
that thursday and they deal with it
people are used to this in the business
world another important thing to
practice and learn as a creative
professional is learning to say no very
hard to say no you want to do every
publicity opportunity that arises you
want to say yes
when people write you emails that say
hey can i take you out to dinner and
pick your brain you just totally want to
say yes because you know what you had
opportunities like that when you were
breaking in and you want to pay this
back to the community
and that's a good instinct but it's so
easy to say yes
to the point that you are unable to
continue your you can't say yes to
everyone and coming up with certain
rules and criteria that allow you to say
no is a just a really good plan that
when something falls outside of that you
just say you know what i'm gonna say no
they can't do it on a thursday i maybe
just have to pass on this opportunity as
good as it would be because i have too
many things already to do on the
thursdays i can't let it take my my my
time on the other things i have to say i
have a blanket i just say no to going
out to dinner with fans now i just can't
do it anymore i used to do it and try to
help out but i could be at a meal every
hour of every day of the week i could be
signing books every hour of the day for
years and not get through everyone's
books and so
coming up with these rules and saying
this is what we do uh back before
kovid
we had a brandon can do one event a
month
that's it and if events is already
scheduled that month and someone comes
to us and says we really want branded
can we do this and that month of
schedule we just say i'm sorry we can't
do this brandon is booked that month and
we just go ahead and and let that be our
rule because there are times in my
career the words of radiance era that
i've mentioned earlier when i was
starting to explode in popularity this
is where i first hit number one on the
times list these rules have helped me
quite a bit in keeping the focus on what
i want to do most which is write the
books
fantastic there you go
amazing stuff baby
that's how i the lens through which i
see everything yeah no i've been finding
that like
basically all of your writing specific
youtube videos are also very good just
like general life advice create for
advice
it's it's always interesting and thank
you so much this has been an absolute
joy any final message you'd like to to
say to the people watching
no enjoy it find a way to enjoy it i
think the way your philosophy up let's
figure out how to make the things that
you need to do more enjoyable is a
really good philosophy in life to have
amazing and i will use that as the the
the quote uh for the book
all right thank you so much brandon
thanks everyone for watching and we'll
see you we'll see you next time alright
so that's it for this week's episode of
deep dive thank you so much for watching
or listening all the links and resources
that we mentioned in the podcast are
going to be linked down in the video
description or in the show notes
depending on where you're watching or
listening to this if you're listening to
this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the itunes
store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full hd or 4k on
youtube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching do hit the subscribe
button if you aren't already and i'll
see you next time bye